きーみーたん中は自撮りする会動画撮る自撮りは好きなんですけどもあんまりこうね
スマホとかでこうこういう地鶏とかあんまり牧師ないんですよ一度にあんまりしないん
ですけれども
まあせっかくの機会なので今日は一人某デビューしようと思います
相次いで去ってきましたこちら地鶏棒です地鶏スティックを買ってきたんですけど
を全くでも使い方が分からないんだよ
さあ皇居ってこれでつけると取れるって事でしょすげー
連絡すごいなぁん
あっここいいところそ人が来なくて広いスポットをちょっと見つけました
すごいなぁ大対バンしなきゃ
もうすごいな自動でも楽しいなこれぐらい伸びるんですよねこれぐらいの人洸を好きな
場所からこのかっこいい自分と言って負けなんですけどもう俺はそんなもんじゃ満足し
ねえぞ
これじゃねぇこれこの距離この距離分しか取れないからこんなんだろあまりね全体的に
わからないんですよ
俺はもっともっと広い9校もっとこう自分がいまどこ
アニメ甲冑のもっとみんなに伝えたいからもっと長い地鶏棒を作りたいわけなんですよ
準備で今回はこちら60cm の鉄パイプを20本さらにその鉄パイプをつなぐ
ジョイント部分を19個買ってきたので最後10m 5 a のジブリ望郷は作ってね
どうせ写真撮るならた全体的にさあ今なんか全部わかるやつ撮りたいジャベール今日は
10名
メートル越えの超長い地鶏棒をつくって俺が今どこにいるかを全世界と
この
ハートを込めてみんなに伝えようと思いますさせて作っていきましょうよ
なーんだレッツ by ぽつなごう頑丈だから多分を折れないですもう声火事
こういう感じでどんどんつなげていきたいわけよイケルジュードゥア
いけないけどいけるいけるいけるいけるいける
はいとりあえず全部あーもーん喘鳴等分に本著で具体者てたので[ __ ]っ
この後全文1本にツンだけでいこうと思います
4車線道大道だいどうだい完成しました
ん
めちゃくちゃで金リコーダーみたいじゃ今回もいただいたん
間違ってが映りよ
でっ
iphone いいきれいなんではセットしていきます
ok でしょそれでは
サラの旅をお楽しみください持ち上がったらいいな
持ち上がれば活躍館ん
最強の地鶏棒の自撮りがこちらですどうぞ
ge 2
tan
はん
持っ
います
ブーブー
を
んをっ
を打ってるん
おおおおおおおおおお
これを期に
持ったん
くるのはもう
をポップ
このを